[Music]
as far as we know there's only one thing
in our solar system sophisticated enough
to study itself the human brain but this
self investigation is incredibly
challenging a living brain is shielded
by a thick skull swaddled in layers of
protective tissue and made up of
billions of tiny connected cells that's
why it's so difficult to isolate observe
and understand diseases like Alzheimer's
so how do we study living brains without
harming their owners we can use a trio
of techniques called EEG fMRI and pet
each measures something different and
has its own strengths and weaknesses and
we'll look at each in turn
first is EEG or electroencephalography
which measures electrical activity in
your brain as brain cells communicate
they produce waves of electricity
electrodes placed on the skull pick up
these waves and differences in the
signals detected between electrodes
provide information about what's
happening
this technique was invented almost a
hundred years ago and it's still used to
diagnose conditions like epilepsy and
sleep disorders it's also used to
investigate what areas of the brain are
active during learning or paying
attention
EEG is non-invasive relatively
inexpensive and fast it can measure
changes that occur in just milliseconds
unfortunately it's hard to determine
exactly where any particular pattern
originates electrical signals are
generated constantly all over the brain
and they interact with each other to
produce complex patterns using more
electrodes or sophisticated data
processing algorithms can help but in
the end while EEG can tell you precisely
when certain activity occurs it can't
tell you precisely where to do that
you'd need another technique such as
functional magnetic resonance imaging or
fMRI fMRI measures how quickly oxygen is
consumed by brain cells active areas of
the brain use oxygen more quickly so
watching an fMRI scan while a person
completes cognitive or behavioral tasks
can provide information about which
regions of the brain might be involved
that allows us to study everything from
how we see faces to how we understand
what we're feeling
fMRI can pinpoint differences in brain
activity to within a few millimeters but
it's thousands of times slower than EEG
using the two techniques together can
help show when and where neural activity
is occurring the third even more precise
technique is called positron emission
tomography and it measures radioactive
elements introduced into the brain that
sounds much scarier than it actually is
PET scans like fMRI and EEG are
completely safe during a PET scan a
small amount of radioactive material
called a tracer is injected into the
bloodstream and doctors monitor its
circulation through the brain
by modifying the tracer to bind to
specific molecules researchers can use
pet to study the complex chemistry in
our brains it's useful for studying how
drugs affect the brain and detecting
diseases like Alzheimer's but this
technique has the lowest time resolution
of all because it takes minutes for the
tracer to circulate and changes to show
up these techniques collectively help
doctors and scientists connect what
happens in the brain with our behavior
but they're also limited by how much we
still don't know for example let's say
researchers are interested in studying
how memory works after asking 50
participants to memorize a series of
images while in MRI scanners the
researchers might analyze the results
and discover a number of active brain
regions making a link between memory and
specific parts of the brain is an
important step forward but future
research would be necessary to better
understand what's happening in each
region how they work together and
whether the activity is because of their
involvement in memory or another process
occurring simultaneously more advanced
imaging and analysis technology might
one day provide more accurate results
and even distinguish the activity of
individual neurons until then our brains
will keep measuring analyzing and
innovating in pursuit of that quest to
understand one of the most remarkable
things we've ever encountered
[Music]
check out our playlist on some of the
fascinating things humans have already
managed to discover about their own
brains
[Music]